El objetivo de este video es ayudarnos a todos
a estimar el número real de casos de COVID-19
por día en nuestras zonas. Esto está basado
en el análisis de Thomas Pueyo que escribió
un blog increíble en medium, este es el vínculo,
y también lo van a encontrar en la descripción
de este video. Esta es la información que utilizó
para hacer algunos de sus análisis. Quizá puedes
estar pensando que conoces el número de casos
de COVID en tu zona, ya que lo informan en las
noticias todos los días, pero ése es el número
de casos reportados y se basa en la gente que
se ha hecho la prueba. Hay mucha gente que quizá
no tenga síntomas aún o que sus síntomas no sean
lo suficientemente graves como para realizarse
la prueba, por lo que el número real de casos es
probablemente mucho mayor que el número de casos
confirmados. Y podemos ver esto de manera gráfica.
Una vez más, este es un diagrama realizado por
Thomas Pueyo, es una captura de pantalla de su
publicación en el blog que podemos encontrar aquí.
Todo esto es un análisis o se basa en su análisis,
y muestra lo que estaba ocurriendo en la provincia
de Hubei, que es donde se encuentra a Wuhan. Y hay
muchas cosas interesantes aquí: el eje vertical
es el número de casos y lo que vemos en el eje
horizontal es la información por día. Entonces
podemos tomar, por ejemplo, enero 23. La barra
amarilla nos dice el número de casos nuevos
confirmados ese día, se refiere a gente que
se hizo la prueba y resultó positiva, y parece
que ese número es alrededor de 300. Pero también
tenemos esta barra gris, esta barra nos dice el
número real de nuevos casos de ese día que es
cerca de 2,500, aproximadamente 8 veces más alta.
Ahora podrías preguntar: ¿cómo saben el número
real de casos si no se les está haciendo la prueba
a todos? Bueno, la forma en que obtuvieron estos
datos es que cuando alguien resultaba positivo
le preguntaban cuándo comenzó con síntomas y
si decían: "Empecé con síntomas hace 10 días",
entonces lo agregaban como un caso nuevo real 10
días antes, en enero 13. Así los funcionarios
chinos pudieron hacer estas barras grises en
retrospectiva, con base en la fecha en que la
gente había comenzado a tener síntomas. Y hay aquí
mucha información interesante. Primero podemos
ver que Wuhan se cerró el 23 de enero. Y vamos
a dibujar una línea entre los datos previos al
cierre y posteriores al cierre. Y podemos ver que
en cuanto los funcionarios de la ciudad comenzaron
a ver casos confirmados, el número de casos reales
era mucho mayor, pero entonces cerraron la ciudad,
lo que desaceleró considerablemente la tasa de
propagación. Y unos cuantos días después los
casos reales que podían calcular en respectiva
comenzaron a aplanarse y después a decrecer.
Pero, aunque éstos estaban disminuyendo, los
casos confirmados seguían aumentando porque había
un retraso, incluso podemos ver el retraso aquí,
y este es aproximadamente el periodo de tiempo
que pasa entre que la gente presenta el primer
síntoma hasta que se hace la prueba. Ahora,
podrías decir: "Bueno, esto no está tan mal,
parece que las cosas finalmente van bien para
Wuhan", pero esto es porque hicieron un cierre
muy serio; si no lo hubieran hecho así, de manera
que la propagación del virus se desacelerara,
veríamos cómo continuaría este crecimiento
exponencial. Y vale la pena recordar que
la curva que acabo de dibujar no es del total de
casos, sino del número de nuevos casos por día. Si
quisiéramos el número total de casos en un momento
dado, tendríamos que sumar todas las barras grises
o las amarillas dependiendo de qué quisiéramos
buscar, casos reales o casos confirmados.
Entonces, para enero 22, si sacáramos el total
de todas estas barras grises para esa fecha,
tendríamos aproximadamente 12,000 casos, mientras
que si sumamos todas las barras amarillas apenas
tendríamos 444 casos confirmados. Así que incluso
antes del cierre de la ciudad, y considerando que
los chinos realizan las pruebas razonablemente
bien, tenemos un número de casos bastante más alto
de lo que nos harían creer los casos confirmados.
Aún cuando la tasa es grande en un día determinado
antes del cierre de la ciudad, entre el número de
casos reales por día y el número de casos nuevos
confirmados por día, probablemente sea mayor
en muchas de las zonas geográficas en las que
vivimos debido a que las pruebas no se realizan
tan bien como lo hicieron en China. Por ejemplo,
y nuevamente esta es información que recopiló
Thomas Pueyo, es su publicación en el post,
es sólo una captura de pantalla, en realidad sólo
estoy ofreciendo su análisis. Esta tabla muestra
el total de pruebas realizadas y las pruebas
realizadas por millón de ciudadanos hasta
marzo 3. Y podemos ver, por ejemplo, que a Estados
Unidos de Norteamérica no le está yendo muy bien,
por lo que el número de casos reportados en
lugares como Estados Unidos de Norteamérica,
en los cuales apenas se está comenzando a
multiplicar la realización de pruebas, está muy
por debajo del número de casos reales. Entonces,
¿cómo hacemos para estimar el número real de casos
en nuestra zona? De nuevo utilizaré el análisis
de Thomas. Veremos los números de muertes y las
estimaciones de la tasa de mortandad, el tiempo
entre la infección y la muerte y qué tan rápido
se propaga el virus realmente. En otros videos
hablaré más acerca de algunos análisis de Thomas;
pero para la tasa de mortandad las matemáticas
serán sencillas, y esta realmente parece ser una
estimación bastante buena. Podemos suponer que
hay una tasa de mortandad de 1%. Hay reportes
tan bajos como 0.6% en Corea del Sur y tan altos
como aproximadamente 5% en lugares como Irán,
pero parece que los números más altos se dan en
donde el sistema sanitario se ha desbordado y el
número más bajo, el 0.6%, puede no estar contando
en su totalidad todas las muertes que ocurrirán
dados los casos reales que existen. Entonces
supondremos una tasa de mortandad del 1%. La
otra cosa que tenemos que considerar es el tiempo
entre la infección y la muerte en ese 1% de casos
en los que alguien muere. Para calcularlo, veremos
la información de este cuadro que se encuentra en
el vínculo que cita Thomas, lo van a encontrar
abajo en la descripción. Este es el periodo de
incubación, es un estimado del tiempo que pasa
entre que una persona se infecta hasta que
comienza a manifestar síntomas, y este estimado es
de alrededor de 5 días. Y, entonces, una vez que
se presentan síntomas, ¿cuánto tiempo pasa hasta
la muerte en ese 1% o el porcentaje que este sea
de casos? Bueno, hay varias estimaciones, pero
parece que para hacer más sencillos los cálculos
podemos estimar alrededor de 15 días; entonces,
una forma de verlo sería 5 días desde la infección
hasta la presencia de síntomas, y otros 15 días
desde los primeros síntomas hasta la muerte,
lo que da un total de 20 días desde la infección
hasta la muerte en ese 1% de casos que estamos
suponiendo. Entonces escribiré 20 días. Otra cosa
que vamos a estimar son los días de duplicación,
es decir, cuántos días le toma a la infección
duplicarse en la población, y esto dependerá en
mayor medida en lo que esté haciendo la población:
qué tan densa sea, cuánto estén interactuando;
pero veremos algunas de estas estimaciones.
Estos son de contextos muy distintos, y entre
más baja sea la tasa de duplicación significa
que el virus se está propagando muy rápidamente,
mientras que si la población está haciendo lo
correcto y está tomando todas las precauciones
la tasa de duplicación será menor. Podemos ver
una estimación conservadora y tomar una tasa de
duplicación mayor a todas estas estimaciones para
hacer más sencillos los cálculos. Supongamos una
tasa de duplicación de 5 días. Estoy utilizando
números un poco distintos de los que utilizó
Thomas, pero sólo son indicativos. Tú puedes hacer
el mismo análisis con las estimaciones que elijas.
Entonces, supongamos 5 días para la duplicación,
lo que puede ser conservador, especialmente para
lugares como Estados Unidos de Norteamérica, en
donde no se han tomado acciones ni remotamente
cercanas a las que se tomaron en China, en Corea
del Sur o en Japón. Utilizamos ahora estos números
para calcular lo que puede estar pasando en
nuestras zonas con base en la información que nos
dan. Digamos que, desafortunadamente, aquí hoy hay
una muerte en nuestra zona o en nuestra ciudad.
Ahora, con base en nuestras estimaciones, decimos
que el tiempo promedio entre la infección y la
muerte es de alrededor de 20 días, esto significa
que la persona debió haber contraído el virus hace
aproximadamente 20 días. Voy a hacer una línea de
tiempo. Esto es hace 20 días, esto sería hace 10
días, esto sería hace 15 días y esto, entonces,
sería hace 5 días. Ahora, es posible que esta
fuera la única persona que contrajera el virus ese
día y que desafortunadamente enfermara gravemente
y posteriormente falleciera 20 días después.
Pero si suponemos que la tasa de mortandad es
más o menos correcta, es bastante posible que 100
personas se infectaran ese día, esa persona de la
que hablamos sería ese 1 entre 100 que realmente
enfermó tanto como para morir. Suponemos entonces
que hace 20 días no fue sólo una persona
sino 100, así que el número real de personas
infectadas ese día es 100. Una vez más, porque
la tasa de mortandad es de 1%. Si supusiéramos
una tasa de mortandad de 0.5% entonces diríamos
que podría haber 200 personas infectadas ese día,
0.5% de quienes llegarían hasta la muerte 20 días
después. Si suponemos un 5% de tasa de mortandad,
lo que sería una situación muy desafortunada, sin
embargo es la tasa que hemos visto en diferentes
partes del mundo, entonces diríamos "Bueno,
quizá haya habido 20 personas infectadas ese
día". Cuando sólo se tienen 2 o 3 muertes en
una zona las estimaciones son más complicadas,
pero como probablemente, por desgracia, veremos
un gran número de muertes en varias regiones,
estas estimaciones en retrospectiva serán cada vez
más razonables. Ahora, si la tasa de infección en
la población se duplica cada 5 días, ¿qué
sucederá ahora? Después de 5 días habrá en
esa región 200 casos, éstos no serán 200 nuevos
casos sino que serán el número total de casos
tomando en cuenta esos primeros 100. Y éste es
un número bastante conservador, porque asume que
estos 100 casos que se infectaron hace 20 días
son los únicos casos en la región. Puede haber
otros casos infectados antes de esa fecha, pero
seamos conservadores y supongamos que estos 100
que se infectaron ese día son los únicos casos.
Entonces se duplicarán después de 5 días y otros
5 días después se volverán a duplicar, entonces
ya tendremos 400 casos en 5 días más, y después
de otros 5 días ya se habrá duplicado de nuevo. Ya
no cabe en la pantalla, pero tendremos 800 casos.
Y esto significa que hoy, por la evidencia de
esta sola muerte, probablemente tengamos -no voy
a poder dibujar toda la barra- alrededor de 1,600
casos. Esto es aleccionador acerca de cuán seria
es la situación y de cómo la información
que obtenemos está realmente desfasada,
particularmente en lugares como Estados Unidos
de Norteamérica, donde apenas se está comenzando
a realizar pruebas. Por ejemplo, en el condado
de Santa Clara, en California, ayer se reportó
desafortunadamente una segunda muerte, y hubo otra
5 días antes. Hay menos de 100 casos reportados en
este condado, pero con base en este análisis el
número real de personas infectadas probablemente
es mayor a esa cantidad, por lo menos por un
factor de 10, y puede ser tan alto como 1,000,
2,000, 3,000 personas. No lo sabremos con
seguridad sino hasta que podamos hacer este
tipo de análisis en retrospectiva que hicieron en
China. Pero esto nos recuerda lo seria que es la
situación realmente. Entonces, la conclusión es
que tenemos que tomar todo esto muy seriamente,
especialmente porque la tasa de mortandad puede
variar dependiendo de qué tan bien equipado esté
el sistema sanitario para manejar la situación.
Si todos nos aislamos socialmente y tomas las
precauciones adecuadas, la tasa de propagación
bajará y no saturaremos el sistema sanitario,
y con suerte podremos mantener la tasa de
mortandad lo más baja posible. Pero si no
tomamos precauciones y si nos quedamos satisfechos
al ver esta información desfasada que nos reportan
debido a la falta de realización de pruebas en
lugares como Estados Unidos de Norteamérica,
entonces es muy posible que lleguemos
a saturar el sistema sanitario en las
próximas semanas, lo que provocaría
el aumento de la tasa de mortandad.